breathing's from podcast Ville its
Wednesday the 25th of March kick this
[ __ ] mealy
[Music]
[Music]
right joel mchale in the house thank you
for having me it's a totally normal day
thank you for coming how are you buddy
I'm you know uh All Things Considered
I'm very well it was great to see at the
store a few weeks ago Larry good to see
you you were out doing your thing I was
happy I love seeing different comics out
during the week I'm just glad they let
me on yeah yeah you had a great set you
had a good time I would lose I'm that
whole crap that was a murderer's row
back there oh my comics I really is very
intimidated so now you started calmly
down here I I did a lot of comedy well
as people like Joey and I were in sea at
the same time apparently but I was on a
TV show in Seattle called almost live
that so I and I was newly married and I
had not ever died did a ton of improv
but no stand-up so I didn't really start
stand up until after like a year after
the soup which everyone goes oh that's
why you suck so hard during that time
when you're trying to stand up but but I
didn't start that after because an agent
said to me you're gonna make a lot of
money if you just go on the road with
your friends and you can introduce them
and then they can go do their thing and
you can try little jokes in between so
but joke technically yeah I guess I
started comedy in Seattle I gotta be
honest with you I enjoyed your
quirkiness on talk soup Oh God I loved
it I loved that people would yell things
and stuff like that I really enjoyed
that and I think somebody polished
wouldn't I had a good time doing that
show yeah well I'm saying that that's
why that's what made you so good for
that show it was a good time yeah well I
were loose you work work I stood
watching episodes at night and laughing
McGuire's girlfriend wrote yes yes
that's why I always followed you know
because she was on there if it was on I
watch it you know we're at in comics you
know you're busy the worst is when
people say you watch my show and you're
like your shell comes on at 9:30 yeah
I'm talking to me at that time I'm out
I'm out you know yeah but
so you go on the road like when you're
on the road Thursday Friday Saturday
usually tend to watch [ __ ] usually
wouldn't watch or you don't have time to
watch anymore now I'm home I can watch
the [ __ ] news or whatever
how long did talk super long for I did
it for 12 years Jesus that was a while
yeah he's got me uh yeah I bought some
stuff yes you did uh but yet no I
believe me I couldn't I didn't I believe
me I was surprised as anybody it went
that long but you say the whole like
polish part but I'm super dyslexic so I
could I could not read a teleprompter
when it started so there was so I [ __ ]
up so much that it would take me I
remember the first few episodes it took
me four hours to get through 20 minutes
a copy 22 minutes a copy and what did
you think to you something I thought
gonna fire me I just kept thinking I
cannot believe I cuz at that point I was
undiagnosed and I was just like these
I'm an idiot but I'm just gonna keep
when they finally edited together
they're like we we salvaged your
performance and then as the anxiety of
having being forced to read jokes on
camera as that went down then I got a
lot and then I began to not care at all
if I screwed up so then a guy I've got
Danica has got good having such a good
time when you don't care that's when
that's right that's good yeah when you
just let loose you know I learned a lot
when I shot specials I wasn't good at
shooting specials because I cared too
much right I focused on the words like
an acne and I'm supposed to focus on the
words I can act that you were stand-up
yeah go out then just go you know go and
look pieces for were there how long did
it take you to figure that out two
specials and I was like I'm done I just
can't do this
but then the third one you win oh no no
but if you're not gonna do it no no I'll
tape CDs from now on and what if someone
secretly taped you and then it was said
if it was a good set yeah then I'll put
it out there I just don't like all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that comes with it I don't
want to see a boom going over me when
I'm doing stay
and uh none of that [ __ ] you know I I
think that we went away from the
traditional way of shooting stand-ups
and now we're trying to get back but
it's too late like I still remember
seeing Lenny Bruce and just a thing yeah
nordian slap in the hands no big theater
to impress you you know just it was just
a wall with bricks on and then maybe 200
people in the room and he went off
that's why they called this nightclub
comics you know we did nightclubs right
you know that's it you know that Ken
Jong taped his at the ice house yes
which he could he could have taped it at
you know an arena if he had wanted to
but it's so intimate and he shows how
claw mean obviously you know how close
it is for those of you are just tuning
in it's very close and and it's magical
I liked it when I shot the special my
first special a shot of a comedy club in
Chicago I really liked that Club I like
the reaction it was outside the city
right so they were more blue collar so
when I work in zany's in the city I just
go there to eat a bag of that like it's
just flying somewhere they suck dick for
five days fine shows so I try to work
one night there they're too intense for
me downtown they're too politically
correct you go up 45 minutes outside of
Chicago thing is a loose yeah they don't
count points then I'll give a flop they
say the word [ __ ] you really should
call your next specialty eating a bag of
dicks yeah that's it it's just it's such
a heart when you I don't like anything
organized like that was why I ended up
doing this [ __ ] racket anyway right
because if you thought I was gonna get
up at 8:00 in the morning and be your
job at 8:00 every morning I just don't
know that seems I'm so insane to do it
okay I could probably make it Monday for
sure after that I'll do like 8:30 9:00
there'll be one 12 o'clock yeah cuz you
know one night you go to the Comedy
Store you twist one up it's all though
but yeah
RINO's you should have lived grew up in
London or England cuz you know by the
time like because what I hear is like
the first day they work second day they
go to the pub for lunch it's kind of a
and just the Wednesday long lunch
Thursday they're going to the half-day
cuz they're already in the bag and then
Friday just don't even count on any
communication at all and yet they were
an empire so long no I don't I didn't
like do you still stay out really late
now no you don't you go right back home
no you got a kid yeah and the house
wakes up at 6:15 whether you want to not
yeah you know the saying there's nothing
up do you know boy sometimes I don't
mind getting up early like I don't mind
it I work my like if I got a spot at the
store it's gotta be early get me out of
there by 11:00 so I could go to bed by
12:30 right I could live on six for a
day or two and then get a good ten or
nine or an A and I'm back tomorrow you
can sleep for ten hours straight I did
the other day for the first time in ten
years
glorious I could not bad I need help
though right yeah like now edibles I
like you're waking up every 20 minutes
says this thing called quick Z's they
sell at urban trees it's just a little
to ounce drink it tastes like kool-aid
you drink that okay
it's got like extra melatonin anything
that puts you to sleep naturally it's
got it's in there but heavy but there's
with a hundred milligrams of THC right
to really knock your [ __ ] that how
long does it last
I don't get up and pee in the middle of
night no more you just wears off here's
the main thing for me is not getting up
to pee going to bed drinking water yeah
and being able to hold it in and like if
I could get from midnight to 7:00 with
without a pee like if I can get up at
7:00 and pee I'm good
I'll get another how out of it too late
because of what's been going on the last
three weeks at the school and stuff the
week before they got let out to go to
school I was supposed to go back to New
York shoot at it scenes with Soprano
prequel and I was losing it Joe cuz
there was losing it bones a call time
know know how to I had to go to New York
I did not want to go to New York in the
middle of this band that like right and
I could see it coming every day I'm like
it's not gonna one then they started
shooting on Wednesday I'm like obviously
these [ __ ] aren't paying
attention for the news then New Rochelle
got smothered and that's right next door
all the places I'm gonna be shooting and
then Thursday it's spreading worse you
know Trump he knows know what to do and
I'm Paul I'm going guys are you sure you
want us to fly back east because I don't
think will happen at first my fear was
not getting back and that week I had to
do extreme measures to fall asleep like
there was tonight there was one man I I
stand up a little while I had a little
stress over taking the flight and then
the next night it was the night I drank
the whole tube with a bunch of edibles
and usually all right so I play on the
computer this way like everybody at home
does right like straight up so if I fall
asleep how'd you fall asleep like this
and I'll put my head up and look at the
computer see what time it is
are you playing a game on the computer
I'm watching YouTube okay I'm listening
to YouTube on my computer but I'm typing
on the iPad you are I'm listening
because they come listen to YouTube I'm
the Big Apple but I have the iPad and
I'm typing and you know jokes whatever
yeah trying to clean up [ __ ] that's not
gonna work and then I didn't even feel
myself get the position be right this is
position B that's a good position to
wake up it that's not too bad if you
just lay your head on this on the things
ruling all over the place no not at all
now this position B and position C is
when you're away from the computer and
you just love in your lap right so last
week two weeks ago
I actually woke up in position deep
which is right from here with a chance
there's a heater and that's how I woke
up the heater was burning off my back
pubic hair that's your daughter walk in
and go dad's dead no no she's in bed at
[ __ ] nine o'clock right this is going
on at 11:00 11:30 she's out of that room
did you read that thing by Steve Martin
when he took ambien and because some
people sleepwalk on ambien where he when
you could online gamble for money when
you could do that a few years ago no he
like was gambling and he went to bed
took an ambien and then the next day he
went to go play poker again and he
noticed there was more money in his
account and so he wouldn't look back in
his history and he had gotten up for two
hours and played poker from like 4:00 to
6:00 a.m. and had no idea he had played
and he won during that time so if I were
him I would have just taken an ambien
and sat down no I don't like the
ambience yeah that's a while ago and I
just didn't like that one time it just
wasn't for me
oh I it's like when I fly to New York
especially those early flights at the
overnight flights yeah taking an ambien
no thanks for you I've never taken a
xanax in my life you'd rather go with
the air Mia someone said that xanax
actually this guy who worked for the
company that sold it he's like stick
with a ambien because xanax is very
habit for me and I was like this is
coming from the guy who sells it where
we have before any of us you don't wanna
he goes you don't to mess with it too
much and I was like okay good to know
I will just have more wine I'll have
another glass of wine please
but have do tags antics I'll take the
xanax
hello 80.2 fives would you take that
with the sleep thing oh yeah can you go
hard or like an hour or an hour and a
half during the night no wonder you know
if I take if I take an edible and I go
out into a public place like Guns and
Roses or something like that I'm gonna
need a xanax it's
point of the night so I'll bring two of
those footballs with me there's little
footballs at 0.25 I don't know they've
been nothing they I do them before
comedy and does it take the edge off
takes the edge off like if I have to go
to the Comedy Store 9 or 10 times my
wife watches and I don't even take them
I forget to take them so sometimes I go
to the store and I have a little anxiety
I'm the drive and I'll just power
through it and then once I get down in
the anxiety goes away sometimes it comes
back and I'm covered so wait what did
you say your wife did your wife she you
said she are you you did you say I maybe
I misheard but you said she washes it or
what was your I leave him in my jeans
oh she washes I forget to take them
right because I try not to take them so
you don't get hooked up right right
right so there's a benzo addiction so
what I do is I'll put two in my jeans
and then I might have to remember to
take them out and put them back in the
tent there's the nights I'm leaving for
the store and I'm starting to get
anxiety go let me bring them with me
just in case I have a full-blown attack
you still get nervous onstage
oh no before really before and it's just
no fun
mmm No so there's got like the last real
big anxiety attack I got was June 2nd
March 2nd at the store because after I
went to Vegas on the 29th they said
Vegas was at 50% the corona virus is
already starting people paying attention
right but we weren't
and also I'm like dr. Dre just being a
50% one
yeah what's happened up they said that
every and I went to the yep when I was
the third guy in the TSA line okay
things are changing spinners a change
something's not right
I landed I told my wife why I went
online I did a little research you know
and then I went to the store Tuesday
night and I went into the main room
listen to me and I walked around that
edge and when I opened the green room to
the main room there was 18 people in
there talking and no windows that sets
me off huh why do you think that doors
open the habla I'm gonna be the first to
be shot cuz my back to the door no no no
because I don't want to getting all this
[ __ ] is put anxiety on me huh it puts
like a silent anxiety yeah do you wind
up wind up door closes on a plane do you
not at all doesn't bother you not not
yet I know I've told people for years I
don't even understand how I get on a
plane
my love for comedy and for doing what I
do
over-over whatever right I'm Safi think
it's because you got a job to do and you
have to go to have a job and that's the
thing this is the thing that gets me
there yeah you gotta take me on how
before the car is coming so let's say my
flights at 6:30 come to my house at 3:00
and see what I look like I'm not happy
wow I'm not happy yeah how interesting
I prefer sleep apnea machine away I'm
not happy once I get new bruh I'm happy
what do you like them second you walk
office walk offstage I'm [ __ ] happy I
was there yeah bandhas thank God I'm not
a [ __ ] I don't listen to myself and
cancel a weekend or if you do two shows
a night is did you have anxiety between
the shows no because once you get one
down once I get one done I'm good
it's that first one that is just hard
and sometimes it isn't sometimes it
isn't it's a 50/50 toss-up I'm never
gonna know how to react I do always get
anxiety before I go onstage what level
of is that's like a control so if I walk
into that green room at the store and I
see you and there's a few other people
there and you haven't gone on yet are
you in a mild state of anxiety I'm gonna
midst a them anxiety you're talking
about your kids and your life and I love
you to death but I don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking right I'm just
guessing you did that really you're just
like Graham listening to the audience
and I'm listening to my anxiety building
I can hear people talking in there but
it's like Chinese right well I know it's
like Charlie Brown music doing 12 it's
so interesting at once
go onstage the Charlie Brown music
disappears then I run out of there and I
go to the kitchen I decompress a little
bit now I'm ready for [ __ ] Satan
right now I don't give a [ __ ] bring him
on I already got I already jumped in the
[ __ ] Hudson River if you do multiple
sets of the night not shows but if you
go like imma go here and I'm gonna go do
you after the first one you have any
anxiety no if you're heading to the
improv it's the first one yeah that
first one what throughout the years I've
had to cut down more than anxieties cuz
it was always something with me it was
always something there's too many people
with white hair in the audience what's
too many women in the audience so that's
why I don't - many women in the audience
do and what is tied oh no it's your mind
playing tricks on you when you're a
comic it's called what what the great of
the art of war not sunsoo the other guy
that wrote the book about grinding he
calls resistance into our own body
telling us you know the chicken out to
be a coward it's like you have a
thousand stories that you want to write
write you write three pages and you move
on you know you don't think there's a
plot that there's a plot that you
wouldn't I wrote it that's really your
intention but now your mind throws a
thousand reasons that you why you
shouldn't do it mmm-hmm so it's weird
like I tell you the first time I I cuz
you're from up there I cut my teeth and
Seattle what do you mean by cut my teeth
I did like four years of comedy but
where I started performing for real
audiences for Seattle and that's where
my anxiety started so I took the ferry
the Bremerton yeah Bremerton used to
have a room up there for the Navy isn't
the Navy
yeah then we stocked them absolutely
that's where they keep their submarines
yeah because this is a deepest point
they give you a lot they also keep him
on Whidbey Island right would be island
so you could shoot straight down to
[ __ ] the universe down yeah so I still
remember doing that room he was a great
guy the guy that ran
Bremerton but he always had an older
clientele I was dirty too
well I'm talking old I'm talking like 44
so I'm going up there talking about
[ __ ] and eat [ __ ] and whatever the
[ __ ] I'm talking about I would look at
the audience is like the little [ __ ]
curtain and I was gonna bomb that was I
always had a reason for I was gonna bomb
there was too many old people there was
too many women there was too many young
people they look like Christians you
know now I can tell that what a
Christian looks like I'm a [ __ ] Swami
all of a sudden right you know I
wouldn't make so I would add anxiety on
to me over the years you say [ __ ] the
people that are old [ __ ] the young
people you [ __ ] them if they're enough
the whole audience right know that this
time if people come back then go ah Joe
please be a little considering you're a
client there's a table of 18 gay men and
it to the older he's scared to me
welcome to my world and the persons I'm
going after yeah you know saying
or it could be Joel be careful what
you're saying there's a table of
eighteen nuns out there or 18 rabbis
right how are you gonna act you know I'm
saying like Howie what are you gonna say
are you gonna play to them you use them
to your advantage
walk them you know in my world I was 18
rabbis that's it I'm going to jet you
know now with I would give myself all
these excuses most of the time you were
successful
I mean fifty percent at that point okay
you were I was improvising I was [ __ ]
around so what if you did if it didn't
go well would you go yep
that's exactly what I thought would
happen I knew I was gonna bomb that
table of white haired people [ __ ] me
up to all that oh how was part of that
for a while you're like yep that's
exactly how I thought of my to blame the
audience and would it then when would it
go when it would go well would you have
the would you still be yourself am L
like well that was a fluke or which I'll
be like exactly I will kill them I would
go yeah
look oh my god I made the lesbians laugh
Oh they run realize that people go into
the laughs no matter what they are
they're not going I was I was going on
stage thinking I was gonna get attacked
every time I walked on stage you know
you just learned it yeah just usually if
you're a jet fighter pilot and every
time they like what I can't believe it I
actually flew up another jet and I meant
to shoot that thing down I didn't think
it was gonna happen thought I'm just
gonna crash this thing if they have the
same attitude the comics had it's
[ __ ] crazy what we're both acting
ticket nervously [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ]
yeah you walk out [ __ ] shake the
neros hand hey do you wanna rehearse no
not really
yeah yeah one of ours yeah and you go to
your lines and you don't know his lines
you know his assistant gives him his
lines I get nervous on every level but
then after you do the first one of the
first ten takes a memo shouldn't analyze
that it was just be by myself when I had
a lump on it it must have taken an hour
to say one line for you because I was
focused on my set later on that night
oh that's why if I haven't seen the
movie no more nothing comedy gets
canceled don't well on the side of hate
you don't have to care wouldn't it help
if you had that distraction like later
that night and be like oh I got I got
this acting thing cuz I got this other
thing or was it a that's taking up all
my brain space and I'm not focusing
enough it sounds like it was a second
well it was six o'clock and my show
started a I'm shooting in Kearny New
Jersey and the [ __ ] comedy club is
and whatever I forget where it was it
was like 40 minutes away right that's
huge and we kept doing this scene and we
did it so much with so many different
angles but I started forgetting the
lines why did they shoot it so much
because it was [ __ ] De Niro and Hal
Ramos Harold Ramis right they shot the
[ __ ] out of everything you know there's
some directors that shoot this [ __ ]
I dare it and they shoot it so much that
you actually start [ __ ] up the scenes
I yeah I know what you mean they [ __ ]
shoot him so much that now you're like
that you start to break down on going
guys really well now we're gonna switch
it to this view he's gonna get on top of
Alec optical [ __ ] yourself Cowan
Eastwood the street takes ok yeah and
he's been doing this for a hundred
[ __ ] years three takes one for you
one for him and one for the [ __ ]
camera that's it move on let's switch
the [ __ ] angle but there's some
people drive you [ __ ] crazy
yeah I mean there's some people that
learn the scene on the day while they're
shooting it and it takes them 15 takes
before they're good you're like oh they
just learned these lines that I'll know
them now they know them now the scenes
cooking you know what I mean
I always since day one because I come
from the stand-up world
I've always been prepared to go that's
okay that's more than half of okay even
when I was a [ __ ] junkie I was
prepared to go you know I got there I
already knew my lines and the night
before I knew where the scene was going
if I wanted to improvise I could
improvise something I learned after like
2007 was the more famous the person was
the less prepared he was and it really
pissed me off like I was in shock that I
raised my hand I can never say that into
a famous actor but I realized that some
of these guys they just go from movie to
movie yeah they just go from movie to
movie it's not like it was 20 years ago
thirty when Eddie Murphy did 48 hours
matey to trade in places in 83 Bret and
something else in 84 now they got you
should go from one project to the other
I don't want to drop names here or
whatever I could tell you five guys that
bill meant that they didn't looked at
the script to the first day of the shoot
oh yeah they accepted this movie without
even looking at the script they had like
on the system read it or something
nine-time it's a pretty good script
like the scenes are you and the rocket
great or whatever and they don't even
tell you yeah
oh no I'm you know then I just I just
did this movie and they were telling me
a story about Alec Baldwin and that kid
countable what's his name
Shia Shia LaBeouf yeah they were doing a
plan did you hear about this now build a
plane New York and some theater and the
first day [ __ ] Holly ball when shows
up and they rehearsing these he's got a
script the Charlotte ball goes cut
what's going on with the script cuz I'm
like you gotta be off-book man when you
come here the first day I hadn't heard
that you gotta be off blood Alec Baldwin
said was like I'm gonna [ __ ] is this guy
to talk to me like that no I'm gonna
talk to you this way bro you're a
[ __ ] lead you gotta be off-book
when was this this is what like a year
ago two years ago and then it just
continued like he came in next day this
[ __ ] was off-book again he said
some time again then that's Alec Baldwin
teaches at NYU master class on Mondays
guess who's Charlotte Bois dead shut up
to the class shut up in a classroom and
raised his hand and said what do you
call and after that comes I'm prepared
to this set I did not know and then a
couple days later they showed up his
house and when Alec Baldwin pull up in
front of his building Shila boa's day
with a script and said make sure you
know it tomorrow so the understand me
that's the mentality I growl then it's
Alec and you know how his life Alec how
the road what are you gonna say the Shia
LaBeouf stab you 18 times he's a guy
that slashes himself young movie role
where it's back on what he's gonna do to
you young so I mean and I'm not mad at
Shiloh both for that because that's a
norm yeah I've seen a thousand of those
guys walking on a set and go what a mile
and the first day you're like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
there was a [ __ ] that I got one
of the thing was I would love to throw
him under the bus but I can't
this guy's a well-known star
I met him at wardrobe I was a gentleman
to him he was a gentleman to me it was
very nice the first day the dirt or
fourth day I went to shoot with him when
I got to my trailer they changed the
lines I line up the hemming wardrobe I
didn't go up to him he was next to me in
the chat he said good morning I said
good morning I don't say dicta nobody
and after about 10 minutes he goes you
see they did a scene change I go yeah if
you want after this makeup we could go
outside and run the lines dog he looked
at me like I called them a racial slur
he looked at me and then turned his head
and kept getting worked out I said ok
maybe know something I don't know maybe
Stanislavski that whole morning he
[ __ ] up his lines Oh
who was coming out his knob he was
eating off-camera and then try to do the
scene and food would spitting out of his
mouth and then we started torturing to
his face my people started making little
remarks I had to make a remark that he
looked at me like I was [ __ ] Muhammed
Gandhi you're [ __ ] so it was so then
you went after so everyone's going after
him while neither he's going after
nobody's making a little remarks like
this he's hearing any of this stuff I
guess so
you have to have the [ __ ] a now is on
the same scene yeah what do you mean
he's eating while he like in the scene
yes no no no he's just like hold on sec
I got a no no he would do the same but
in between the same there was food on
the table for us to make believe we're
even now I would take little pieces and
eat it like that and then they would
have to cut but the piece of cheese back
and then cheese to come out of his mouth
and between the takes I can't wait to
hear it this is just [ __ ] hilarious
it was just so I've been used to it yeah
last couple movies I've done with big
names oh my god
soon as they get there they don't even
look they just opened up the script and
they're like but then you've obviously
dealt with some people that when they
showed up it was it was on oh yeah some
other those are the greatest people to
work with
and they come looking for you like well
have a [ __ ] [ __ ] comic are you
knock on my door girl you want to
rehearse the scenes my dick that's hard
yeah well I did spider-man to them
[ __ ] knocked on my door like
three or four times just to go over one
line it's pretty good Alfred Molina
Alfred Molina Alfred Molina so this day
he's got all my respect that guy was
there's just some other [ __ ] that
teacher how to act you're like oh yeah
that's when you can feel oh yeah yeah
that's when the air changes in the room
that's when the weather yeah that's when
you go all this [ __ ] strolling
down we got a new yeah well Joel you've
been on like sets for months and months
at a time what is it and someone who
hasn't acted was it like when someone
comes in and doesn't remember their
lines or does it like is that I hear
stories from Joey of 14 16 hour days if
you're doing that for three months at a
time and someone's just dragging on I
must get in awe it's I was on community
for nine months out of the year for six
well nine months Wow
what was it I guess was more eight now
we have me just when you added it all up
it was so much time but and that our
scenes we were shooting movies for every
episode so it was it wasn't like a lot
of these documentaries like Parks and
Rec or the office which is a wonderful
style but ours was movie like it was we
they shot it yeah and we had a lot of
lines and there were you know I'm sure
you've heard some stories about the cast
member who doesn't like doesn't know
their lines and it just you know just
changes the whole day and they had to
shoot him out and it it he didn't really
want me I'm talking about Chevy who was
so funny when it worked and then but a
lot of the times he didn't he he had all
really hard time learning him but
because there was there was a lot of
lines no doubt but but so they would
kind of shoot him out and that would
kind of change the day and it just was a
system we kind of got used to and
duh yeah I'm sure he'll tear this and
love it but but because he always
thought he kind of knew him but he
didn't really and so it was it would be
it would be like it would be definitely
tough I mean I'm being you can see how
politically I'm being but it was tough
huh if you watch some of the scenes it's
him just a single shot of him but he
could be so funny and that was the
that's what sucked is that he could be
very funny and I mean he's coming back
it just got sold the net that's loose I
saw yeah congratulations well they're
selling it apparently everywhere okay
it's on Hulu and now it's on Netflix are
you not going to start reshooting
anymore
they have people of circulated rumors
around we're shooting more episodes but
I was like I'll wait for that call I
haven't gotten the call yet but yeah it
would be crazy if we could get Donald to
do it that would be even crazier I think
he's the busiest man in Hollywood or was
the businessman in Hollywood and tell
everything stopped but yeah I think he
was supposed to be shooting Atlanta for
the next four months but yeah I mean I'd
do it you should come on I looked a big
great good show uh so yeah I don't know
I don't know I it's one of those things
where you hear rumors and like oh
they're gonna do a movie I was like I
look forward to the call where where
they tell me I'm doing this movie but so
far I haven't gotten that call you know
when I got into this I got into this
full of lazy part of being a stand-up
you know I wanted to check out I had a
failed marriage I what year was that
this is 90 I had become the prison I
really had no future ahead they wouldn't
let me back in the University of
Colorado you know so when I got into
standing I mean I had a job and stuff
and I was a functioning member of
society not really but part time I was a
roofing estimator and stuff had a good
job you know I bought a condo stuff like
that but it just wasn't my life wasn't
something was missing you know and uh
you're like 27 at this point I got into
comedy I stepped on stage and I was 20
years old first time and I knew I knew
right then like there
then just click like I knew I'd read a
ladies and gentlemen Lenny Bruce when I
was locked up and everything made sense
when I got off stage you know then you
move out here and they tell you well you
know if you want to do this you have to
act I went to acting classes I was a
really good student I want to hold
reading workshops I mean trust me I put
everything I just didn't walk on the set
right no I love doing what I was doing I
like the freedom of up stand-up I come I
go get on the plane I get to eat
something new for the weekend you know
all that [ __ ] yeah
acting over the years has become I don't
know it wasn't what I felt about it and
it Stan the passing shitty people on it
you know everything that we do has good
and bad pee yeah you know I couldn't
overcome the acting thing after a while
I got a little sick and tired of the
director that showed up with the hat
with the feather and the Chinese
assistant and the tattoo of the bird and
everybody had to see it I got I got a
little sick oh all that face [ __ ] like I
just had just got on my nerves after a
while and then the breaking point was
2009 for me when I was shooting a
commercial the director was just
obnoxious man and he was saying he was
calling the crew people stupid oh like
one of those guys I know have you ever
run into one of those days where the guy
thinks he's John quad grande - yeah he's
smoking a cigarette and he's just
yelling and asking people are you did
you do you know how to read he was one
of those guys I'm like ah it's gonna be
a heavy night and we were in Long Beach
and it was a commercial for the food
chain not the college junior okay and
then the Carl's jr. has a cousin note
that parties so is Wow Hardee's on the
hell did you know he has a lot of calls
Junie so uh he's got Stockton College
I have a go long beach I want with a
great attitude you know what the [ __ ]
doesn't have a great attitude you're
about to see the national conversation
about your mother you [ __ ] kidding me
yeah I was whistling Dixie unless soon
as I get there see this guy I could tell
I know he's the director we're in for a
long night Shauna he was a director you
know and I just saw how he was talking
to people he was abusing his own
assistant which really pisses me off
yeah the bat yeah you're gonna hire an
assistant you're probably under payin
you're telling her this is gonna she's
gonna meet world.we people you know did
line they get those assistant and now
you treat me like [ __ ] in front of
people
holy [ __ ] so I was like you know what
I'm not gonna say nothing I went out
there I shook his hand like a man the
other guy and that's when the drama
started we had to pull up with an SUV
onto a car and the guy was dead like he
was eating uh chicken parmesan sandwich
when we went up he just played like he
was dead because he had the sauce all
over his shirt cat I was it I pull up
and we get out we look but they had the
car lit inside
so somewhere another disconnected the
[ __ ] brains now that'll do it so we
gotta hang his car and the [ __ ] RVs
going down one beach down the [ __ ]
pier and the guys like doesn't anybody
know how to put on a break and go I put
the brakes on in just second time it
happened again and he made a remark the
third time he made it in the fourth time
he's like what are you [ __ ] stupid
and I go hey you [ __ ] and I just
went off on him I go the tech guy even
tried it the brakes are off who the
[ __ ] you to call me stupid you dumb
[ __ ] and he [ __ ] ran into his
trailer and locked himself in his
trailer and said I was fired [ __ ] it's
3:30 in the morning yeah who are you
gonna call no with second choice yeah
and and everybody was just staying
around for like 10 minutes like we don't
know what to do you really hurt his
feelings I'm like [ __ ] camp and
the staff was like yeah you got you guys
a [ __ ] deck like this is the last of
the three commercials like that shot
like three nighttime commercials the
staff was sick of this guy already yeah
and I went up an old Japanese girl was
outside shaking she was all scared like
he doesn't want to see you right now
that I just playing on the door I'll
listen you got a hundred people out here
waiting for you to work do you want to
keep being a [ __ ] all your life you're
gonna keep being a [ __ ] man this is
very easy we could shoot this and you
could be a man all right
and he came out and he's like nobody's
ever spoke on me like that well you
watch how you speak to people you called
me stupid [ __ ] you got the wrong
[ __ ] guy I don't need this job
let's finish the commercial he was a
little [ __ ] he shot me out and they
sent me home that was it I never took
[ __ ] from nobody again I was like that's
it that's it who was it I don't know
what his name was
I don't know what his name and there's
another dick at CBS another old guy that
thinks he's Johnny [ __ ] director he's
just living on reputation last time I
worked for him I hadn't mentioned
something him to an older guy I don't
know what his name is I know I'm gonna
get they even hired him on CBS and I
said something to him because I'm in my
trailer trying to rest my Melissa I'm
here born in the USA [ __ ] loud and
[ __ ] I go out there I'm like what the
[ __ ] is this
so like the directors good friends of
Bruce Springsteen what do I give a [ __ ]
what are you a [ __ ] good friends with
lower his [ __ ]
I'm from the good side of Jersey not the
spring sing inside of Jersey if I'm
gonna direct I heard he said something
me later on show got cancelled anyway
what was the show
the school our brothers were on it was a
CBS yeah yeah the school our brothers
were on it was like our show but I was I
play the guy at the DMV Julie whatever
brought me in to read and yeah Julie I
forget what her name is she has all the
comedy shows on so yes yeah yeah yeah
absolutely so she brings me in I booked
time to time but that's what got to me I
didn't like the attitude of the
directors I didn't like their attitudes
you know I don't like when people have
that savoir faire I went the USC [ __ ]
at it to listen stupid Queen Latifah
walked out in the jungle she's acting
all right relax you ain't that special
relax with Stanislavski and the method
you ain't that special Ice Cube walked
out of [ __ ] the jungle over here and
Crenshaw hasn't even been on ice gun law
nor the SVU for three years you don't
see him doing Shakespeare at the park so
relax all right it's not that much that
we need all this [ __ ] drama to act
when you get a good director it's it's
true nominal it's magic their attitude
permeates everything it's mine I think
would like the lead actor
yeah actor it's magic yeah I we were
very lucky on community but I remember
this one guy I'd want he wasn't director
he was in Troy he was a he was like a
fill-in guy and I had to have rarely
done this but I pulled him into my
trailer and I was just like what are you
doing what's happening explain to me why
you're being like this and he was like
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I was like
just don't do it again
and treat people well and then there
won't be a problem and he's like you're
not firing me I'm like no I will next
time but let's just be cool all right
really
yeah and I was rx miling Adam what was
he doing that was did you seem like a
nice well we had this guest director who
is brilliant who's very good director
but he was he's British and it's not
Tristram Shapiro of trimmers listen to
this
but the guy he was in charge he wasn't
that maybe he was that he was like a
guest second ad so he was now it because
could the second it maybe was a camera
he was high up on the list of people
work and I can't remember what his
position was but every time the British
director would make some suggestion I
hear the guy go I'm just seeing like
roll his eyes and then I could see other
people noticing that and then I was like
okay coming
the trailer let's talk about it but I
didn't scream at him I just was like hey
no yes I treated like do you have a
problem you suck at this I try I try to
treat it like it's a counseling session
or be like you got something going on
did your dad just D touch you and
whatever it and then that gets them to
kind of go oh I'm so sorry and then I
was like just don't ever I didn't go
like don't ever do it again I'm just
like all right so we're good and I was
like just not gonna do it again so we're
good and then hopefully that then he was
great he was fine for the rest of this
year but yeah you'd like to work with
mr. Steven Soderbergh who I got very
lucky too because he only does two takes
really and he operates the camera
there's no video village you'd love it
real you walk into a room you're like oh
there's four of us yes mr. Sodor but
that was my first ever my first movie
like that
and I was like oh so there's no there's
no camp there's no group of people all
watching 20 different monitors Zack no
just me
I'll tell you what else was different
tonight and I don't mean to sound my god
like a douche bag of nothing you know
where I haven't had one shooting
experience that was very good where New
York have you ever shot new you once
well for the summer uh it was called
deliver us from evil with Eric Bana
directed by Scott Derrickson
and what do you think how long were you
there for three months
oh pretty much well I guess when you add
it all up it was probably a month and a
half but I was like there and back and
forth back home it was uh do I know this
the shoots to be a little different like
there wasn't that much smoke being blown
up your ass like there is here like I
think here that's what else bothers me
that's why I really I like doing TV but
I'd rather do a drama if I do TV I don't
like that [ __ ] fake laugh [ __ ] yeah
and I like live audiences I love taping
upon a live audiences I've shot pilots
where they were done in front of live
audiences I like I love that yes I love
that stuff that is great you know
with all this stuff going on right now I
really wanted to do like at first I said
maybe we'll do a pay-per-view and put
some comics together and stream it you
know what man I was watching tonight
with John whatever on HBO yeah he didn't
have an audience and the show was
horrible oh I kind of liked it good the
other night yeah a lot the audience not
the audience I was like oh my god it
feels kind of we I didn't watch it this
week I don't think it was on this I
think it was it was imported wait so you
didn't like it without the audience the
one last week yeah it was a day was very
strange it was very strange it was very
strange so that's why but I I always
liked that one joke he told about it oh
he was funny as [ __ ] yeah he was funny
as [ __ ] dog China Oliver cracks me to
[ __ ] copies i watch that show i
resilience - Oh John Oliver cracks me up
John out when he bumps rap [ __ ] I lose
my [ __ ] mind when he starts it's like
the idea I was watching office space
just the beginning of office space and
the one dudes drives away and they flash
to the other dude [ __ ] but then
there's a black homeless guy named he
closes a window I love all that [ __ ]
like that type of stuff he was talking
something about the week before bump
into power cuz I'm I love John Oliver
but I notice how weird it was without
the audience it was it was definitely it
was weird he was one of his [ __ ] I
always laughed my ass off that joke
about how to distance yourself from
people just pretend you're a British
parent was so oh my god I forgot all
about that until like just pretend his
throwaway [ __ ] is what kills me yeah not
the straight up [ __ ] like the straight
the first joke is gets me a little bit
I'm waiting for his tags and his last
tag is always a bad [ __ ] oh it's
like his last tag is always like whoa
like you that's it case is closed and he
starts all over again
and he lullabies you yeah but you don't
expect the guy that looks like that to
talk that way like I know I expect them
to be geeky and to talk to me boy
triglycerides and [ __ ] he's out there
[ __ ] throw it knowledge so that's why
I enjoy but that's why I didn't want to
do stand-up just to a [ __ ] camera
I rather talk to come in here and talk
to a camera guys keep your lives
together you know go on mug somebody go
get a gallon of milk I don't [ __ ]
know you're free originally from Seattle
how they do pretty much I lived in New
Jersey for two years guys did you really
as a child growing up uh yeah I we
bounced around a little bit but we ended
up I loved it Haddonfield New Jersey
outside of Cherry Hill oh that's nice
that's why people would sivilize can't
see come from up north with those
animals up there yeah Ken's Dominican
Xena I guess yubin's the [ __ ] animals
it was like why does people say New
Jersey is awful that's lovely
that's nice down there no I but I see
how it's where I grew up and I didn't
know how great it was growing up I was
like now I look back I was like oh we
had it was a paradise we were there for
all the grunt stuff all that I graduated
from high school in 91 oh never mind
came out it was and you loved it all you
and I loved it all I went to it all
Mother Love Bone
although jail I hope you went to that
[ __ ] - I never saw Mother Love Bone I
would love to I was like who'd you see
up there I saw I saw Nirvana's last show
in Seattle no you do that was pretty
good I used to watch Jane's Addiction
get booed off stage and not Jade's
excuse me Allison chains get booed off
stage because this band called the young
fresh fellows was more popular at the
time and I remember Layne Staley who
were tannic screaming at the audience
going this is [ __ ] great music we
want the young fresh fellows and then
the young fresh fellows they were the
band in Seattle until crunch really came
in and like the posies and of course
Nirvana and Pearl Jam and Soundgarden
like still sanitizing
you got a senate side as always but no
it was were you were there for part of
it I got there in 95 yeah so it was
[ __ ] brutal he was just amazing just
you know one time the singer from Pearl
Jam went to al-qaeda yeah a little dying
in there because on the tail end of out
I this is 95 so there's a bike replaced
and on Wednesday night was talking all
night [ __ ] the best tacos in the
world tons of people and how can you
just walk down the boardwalk or you
could walk on the sidewalk seven and
then towards the end all the way where I
lived like a block away was a little
diner and I got up that morning when I
went to get in the car and looked and it
was like did I'll exaggerate there was
maybe 50 people standing outside cos
Eddie Vedder was eating breakfast in the
corner table
could you imagine that is [ __ ] crazy
I got to meet Chris Cornell's old wife
Oh cuz she was staying at the comedy
underground sooo silver she was just
hang out yeah she had a friend somebody
she knew upstairs where the old
underground was do you know what that
was it gets all gone now
yes it's all gone by the stadium yeah
somebody's yeah and then there was an
earthquake in 2001 up there yeah wrecked
a lot of yes didn't knock him down but
they were all old and they were got
condemned and that was that I still AM
of being at the underground doing comedy
and there was a club down the corner I
was very well kept no windows nobody
really knew about it
Hart was performing heart worth that and
now that's why I always hear like heart
and Chris Cornell I'm like how does
heart oh [ __ ] that's right hardest in
Seattle yeah they start a bad animals
they started bad animals or something up
there so when's last time you win when
the judge asked me to leave Oh No
January of 97 you've got to get why
haven't you done comedy up there because
I got a warrant up there oh you're not
allowed to know it all started with a
jaywalking ticket in the you district
you got a jaywalking ticket in the users
form you came up to me on bicycles and
skin it out like I've committed a crime
you would have thought I'd kill somebody
Wow with bicycles pulled up next to me
needs to be a movie theater in the new
district so now the district is this way
Bruce Lee school is over here and all
this [ __ ] yeah if you went that way like
there was a movie theater you mean in
Neptune the big old one there's an old
one where I went the second was oh yeah
old I wants to see things to do in
Denver when you're dead there and a
couple other movies then there was a
bigger one that's what I want to see the
body God job [ __ ] like that's the grand
illusion I was telling God I was so you
walked across the street these cops
started with a jaywalking ticket they
just escalated after that it just
escalated
then the jaywalking ticket I didn't go
to court because I figured who gives a
[ __ ] about a jaywalking ticket they came
and got me they knocked on your door I
said you have a $3 warrant they
handcuffed me with pajamas on took me
down there and then I got in trouble
with a girl we got into an argument so
they said it was harassment that we yell
at each other over a parking spot oh my
gosh and I got accused of having a
stolen car I was selling cause of the
dealership and they gave me a car to
drive over the weekend I got pulled over
and registered stolen it was a stolen
the Bank enjoy it was held in the
weekend I just had the worst two years
of my life up there so if you go up
there now you get arrested for what
failing to go to anger management class
in 1997 if anyone in Seattle is
listening if there's a judge up there I
know your guys are very busy right now
but please allow Joey back to see the
place can you [ __ ] believe that that
is crazy so I go to Puerto it's an onyx
traditional warrant I can basically go
to Portland and Idaho I can't go to
Seattle and it was this was I got into a
fistfight at the comedy with the
underground which really wasn't my fault
at all but it violated the probation
for the [ __ ] the harassment thing so
this is what [ __ ] me up even more
I got a rest of the anger-management
class because I got into a fist play
they had nothing to do with me so other
than the assault of harassment and the
Grand Theft Auto is what the grand theft
auto drop because it with the car we get
yeah oh yeah they pulled me over on a
Friday night I just left work I'm like
why'd you pull me over they said your
plates come up stolen I know they can't
they're a dealer plate he goes of that
car the VIN whatever and they figured
out the plate was the stolen the car and
they let me out Monday cost me a week of
my life it's not on my record jeez you
gotta get up there you would not believe
it and the attorney that [ __ ] got me
out of my mess ran a scam what was the
scam she got me a little she know this
is Seattle have you done a background
check on me and they didn't know about
my felony in Colorado so she got the
felony pushed through in Seattle
misdemeanor she did like some kinky [ __ ]
she goes they're not gonna catch it
don't worry about it they do it's on me
they never caught it so the funny thing
was I get an article ten years later
from Ron Reed she got this barred from
being an attorney but she was [ __ ] an
inmate one of her clients was an inmate
she was she was up and thinking now she
was a piece of ass I slipped why isn't
this a TV show I have no idea I got so
many TV shows in my head that you
wouldn't even believe there's like
community plus what was the felony stand
in Colorado what the [ __ ] was the felony
for in Colorado the assault charge at
Comley underground and then they reduced
it to like misdemeanor something but
they were supposed to you still had to
go into prison stayed in county jail for
six days yes Seattle was a bad luck
place to me from day on I just had bad
luck but the comedy scene was so [ __ ]
amazing to call me at that time was I'm
here today because of that three-year
stint I didn't see how good it was every
night from when I Chi you know the
tri-cities [ __ ] redraw me all over the
place everywhere for those listening the
tri-cities is not a suburb of Seattle no
that's a four hour drive yeah well can I
knew I had a car that the exhaust is
broke so blow the exhaust in the car
tried to pull over every hour write a
suicide note cuz it baby dizzy and [ __ ]
and breathing in the exhaust I did my
time Joel McHale just like you you did
your time I did it at well I did a
improv show remember in Walla Walla
Washington
wah wah oh my god yeah then I uh prison
there oh yeah that's the rough precise
the rough prisoners Monroe state prison
which is like the good one that's the
one you want to go to and then there's
Walla Walla
I did improv I improvised at Monroe
State Prison as an outreach to the
inmates for the good inmates they
brought in improv troupe and we did
shows for them wooden trouble impromptu
it was uh it was called unexpected
productions part of theatre sports which
was a national franchised version of a
improv thing which was team was a team
teams have improvised what kind of they
try to create it like a like it feel
like a sporting event which it worked
very well and I learned tons I really
talked about getting on stage every
single night and cutting my teeth but
yeah we went to a prison and it was the
greatest they were the most well behaved
greatest audience members we had ever I
had a pretty because I did some like
corporate gigs where you like for a law
firm or something and you'd be like what
can you give me a profession
gynecologist [ __ ] and really got it got
it and then with the inmates they were
so well behaved because they were so
happy that there was Outsiders there and
then you'd meet like some nice old man
he'd be like well what's he in for he
seems like the nicest man who's like oh
he stabbed his wife 5890
the dog I remember that is like he did
what hmm yeah you'll meet those guys in
there they're kind of nice yeah old they
just kind of lose it and then all the
young guys were there it was always well
I got high with some friends and someone
wound up dead and I didn't I didn't
snitch and I'm like so what happened
they're like I don't really know but
somebody died and I'm not gonna tell on
anybody like okay but it was the first
time like people who had been there for
30 years they'd be like tell me about
what cars are like now and then you look
well they're like cars always were
they're like yeah but like the stereo
and like you've explained and I was like
oh right you don't have any of this
stuff so strange to explain they were
sweet guys and they were all they were
all in the program to do very like to
get out but I've had like one woman she
was like oh yeah that guy just got in he
he just it was like he killed three
people and I Drive by he was like he's
in for life I was like oh my gosh
I was like how old was either like he
was tried in as adult he's 17 and we
okay yeah crazy times what do you got
coming up man
you're looking at everything is
postponed really isn't you everything
you're doing postponed
I had nothing what are you talking about
a couple weekends ya know I had a couple
weekends but that's it I mean every I
was supposed to do I was I was gonna
have two movies at the Tribeca Film
Festival which I was excited about and
yeah I mean these are not what you look
at obviously I always kind of magic
we're like right there are ER doctors
right now being infected because they're
working their asses off right my
brother's an electrician who is like
trying to build help build structures to
house people that are quarantined in as
fast as they possibly can and and then
my other brothers a priest so he's
constantly reading people like their
last rites so so I'm like yeah my my
movies at the Tribeca Film Festival got
pushed so I was kind of mad but said
that was gonna do that I was gonna shoot
the game show card sharks on ABC this
summer May
and that we were supposed to be shooting
that literally right now the regular is
that an older game show it started in
the early seventies okay it is the
simple I like it so much because it's
the simplest game in history but you can
win a [ __ ] so it's like it literally is
just yeah okay you have a - you think
the next car we're gonna pull is higher
lower higher alright there's a queen
next card higher or lower but every card
that gets turned it's another 50 grand
and then people have watched people like
shape like I watched this one woman when
she wasn't about 300 grand and she was
like I was a I was I was it was like a
great acting moment I was like oh this
is what happens when you win the lottery
people go not anyway so all the
stand-ups I'm pushed I had a bunch of
corporate stuff it's all them pushed
it's all like Spring Break canceled all
that that beat again there are people
that have to work everyday through this
thing so I'm you know we're all I'm very
grateful all the first responders people
that are out there yeah they're what the
supermarkets I got none they complain
about
I really don't there's nothing to do
it's funny it's their people two hours
you get a call from somebody upset and
you talk Amal for lunch yeah and Lana
you get put on the ledge for an hour
awful edge and that's it it's been just
adjusting working out riding a little
bit right and we're lucky that we get to
do this yeah okay I have so many friends
in the restaurant business that oh it's
not forget it's done it's it's gonna
there's no way they're gonna only
there's only gonna be chains after this
because I don't know how you if you've a
decent restaurant and you own it and you
don't have any income for a week it's
gonna go down so let alone a month it's
gonna be very sad I hope that I can't I
can't him could you imagine what if you
like walking down the streets of New
York right now a little I mean there's
obviously I'm very curable to walk
through see these Spanish Steps empty in
Rome is so bananas and you know you
can't leave you the house in New York
right like I'm pretty cuz I have some
buddies then and that like they can't
even go to the grocery store they're
getting a delivery isn't it there's the
only delivery that's what I mean that's
what that one guy said hey
well I think you can do essential you
can go shop for the office you got it
work you gotta do little fingers if not
you know if not I don't I don't go out
okay
they don't want you to [ __ ] go out
right so you where I go out it's go out
the [ __ ] no way you're not supposed
to be which every place is closed right
even at the park down the corner they
put cones up now Wow consistent speed
yeah because they didn't know how to
[ __ ] the distance themselves well people
are going to the beaches there's no
people yeah they love them but I will
say get takeout food if you're if you
hear this go to your local don't go to a
chain they're gonna be fine
but go to locally owned small businesses
and get your takeout food or get it
delivered somehow because they're all
gonna go out your favorite restaurant is
unless it's I don't know unless it's the
Cheesecake Factory but every other
restaurants going out of business that's
not a chain so yeah Go Go support them
just give them some money you got it I
do imagine how much money Jeff Bezos is
gonna make in the next month because you
look at cuz you everyone goes like in
times like these right all business goes
down but somebody's making money yeah
and if you're making a hand sanitizer or
toilet paper or you're Jeff Bezos you're
doing or you're a meal delivery all the
money it's [ __ ] crazy we live in
strange times Joe thank you for taking
thank you but I would say isn't it weird
that your daughter's gonna look back at
this oh my god the same way they're
gonna be like oh I remember when we
couldn't leave I remember mom and dad
watching the TV and being all freaked
out and seeing the numbers all he was
like they're gonna look back and go
that's she can't wrap her head around it
she knows something's off I don't put
the TV on the daytime nobody puts the
team rag the house in the daytime you
put it on at 5:00 you know and if I
shall watch a cartoon when I watch World
News Tonight and I turn it off because
you can't get you know what's going on
yeah you know what's going on why are
you killing yourself with the team you
need and that's the same thing yeah it's
your anyone in the internet and get a
heart attack be my [ __ ] guest
in the meantime my 12 year olds like I
got the 99 Russel Wilson on Madden so
whoa I'm gonna be very happy for me yeah
we got a guy from the church that sends
me books I lined them up and I've been
on a [ __ ] reading spree so I'm
catching on the church yeah guy that a
young Mormon no no the Church of what's
happening now out he listens and he
sends me books so now is a great time to
[ __ ] read yeah yeah I read on planes
and on the road that's where I do my
best reading when I'm on a plane yeah
cuz I know I'm gonna be I'm bothered for
[ __ ] three hours look cookie reading
right now right now I'm finishing up the
man who led Zeppelin it's about Peter
Grant huh Led Zeppelin's manager I'm
reading that to finish it because I
started it like three-quarters I'm
finishing it up next I have a couple of
interesting books I want to read this
one on Robert Plant
there's one on Van Halen another buddy
mind game and that's supposed to be good
every morning I eat I read the heart of
war just to get me through this just not
the sons ooh one but the other one okay
the war of art she loved that me to me
yeah it's got a lot of great points in
that they have workshops and they're
little things you could do suddenly it
keeps your mind sharp man
have you read that Andre Agassi book
open not yet oh yeah this is a good one
okay I know I love tennis but a friend
who doesn't like tennis doesn't care
about tennis recommended it and I read
it and I like biographies and I love all
that is hair-raising I love all that
[ __ ] I love reading nothing better for
me I like getting stoned and music this
number one but number two is getting
stoned oh one that so and when you take
the little drink that little the sleep
asleep times e yeah D do you feel groggy
in the morning no no you wake up like
ready to rock that's why I tell people
one opiates Davi you're killing yourself
to live right if I take
300 milligrams for of THC I wake up a
little groggy but nothing than a coffee
and a Cuban coffee because once you take
a [ __ ] the THC leaves your body pretty
much huh it goes on the next car go you
know saying yeah if they examined yeah
so it goes on next car goes so that's
what I don't like like from time to time
I go on the road and some of you give me
a purpose hand or whatever the [ __ ] up
my I don't like how I feel next day when
I go to the dentist and they give you
narcos I don't like that you feel next
yeah my dad got a hip replacement yeah
everything they gave him opiates and he
I was like oh that's not my dad right
now yeah and he's like he's the only guy
that's had a hip and knee replacement
that he got off them almost the day he
like the next day I was like I want to
drink wine I don't I'm tired I hate
these opiate when you get that stuff you
do it the first two just to tell you
your friends you go and then throw them
away you know make em yogurt does it not
they [ __ ] up your stomach they do this
so bad for you all those over yeah so do
you ever see John Oliver's thing on it
no oh yeah oh it's so great it's really
great today they show he shows this
video of people talking about how great
oxy is like it was part of their
promotion and then he went John went
back and found everybody in that video
and it's incredible cuz every one of
them's like my life is oh my life ended
that yeah and it's great crazy
yeah all right si prolonged your no I
don't give a [ __ ] you could sit here
till 6 o'clock in the night
what's the longest one three hours how
long have we done an hour
keep him life of people don't wanna
three hour podcast then she gets she
fell on here and do eight no no all
right you should have at home whatever
the [ __ ] he is in West Virginia wherever
he look he's in Ohio yeah he's in Ohio I
didn't yes he's thankful if he could
take a brunette flex checks just yeah
falling from the sky for him fine he
all those guys are fine so if Netflix
came to you and said we want to do a
special would you do it I don't know all
right I'm here as a representative
Netflix and I would like to offer you a
million dollars for your special would
you would you like to do that let me
think about it
two million okay
four and a half million let me think
about it - push let me think about
helicopter rides I just wanna be happy
yeah I gotta figure out what good is
that two million if I can't figure out
how to make it happy
sheriff you wouldn't give me two million
you wanted to do a lot of things so I
got a way that I'm making on 1 million
and you do me a favor all right give me
the million get the [ __ ] lost leave me
alone leave me I don't want to hear you
I will take this message back to Ted
Serrano yeah I don't want to hear none
of your [ __ ] don't put your reps
around me leave me the [ __ ] alone
I picked the destination just send the
cameraman and maybe some other guy and
that's it I don't want another [ __ ]
that comes through that I won't talk to
you but State Department I don't want to
talk to none of those [ __ ] what if
you like what if you got to the point
where you're like okay they're gonna pay
me ten million dollars unreal and you
figured out you've got this killer hour
like you're like oh I know exactly the
hour I'm very excited and then they go
cool we have to shooting in Seattle then
we'll figure it out all right then we'll
[ __ ] figure it out because I'm not
going up there I'm not doing the three
days they're gonna arrest you on the
stage yeah they want me to turn myself
in and go through the process I want I
because we should take a road trip to
see out I'm gonna smuggle you up there
so you can see what it looks like listen
ma'am well I have bad luck I don't go
back they just been that's why I had it
sorted that's why I love that you know
what you know what I'm so happy about
about this coronavirus I'm sad that
people don't die I'm really sad that
people don't wanna get hit financially
but there's some perks to this I don't
have to take a picture with nobody you
get yeah okay that to me makes me as
happy as I gonna be right there ever
again I don't ever have to take a
picture with anybody ever
again from now on I'm always gonna have
the coronavirus you're like I'm sick I'm
sick as a [ __ ] you own again you
know why because we have to live off the
memory again yeah okay what the [ __ ] is
a picture do you have you you know there
was so many things we just got out of
hand with what the [ __ ] is a picture
gonna do for you listen you know it's
gonna change your [ __ ] life oh it's
gonna remember it and no nobody gives a
[ __ ] this will make you go back into
your [ __ ] memory and get my things
you know and I don't even know what the
point was but here's what's more well
I'll set my lap for the virus all the
stuff that the only thing that really
has scared me every time I get on the
road I go well where is everybody and
I'm going 80 down i-5 through the
transit I'm like I cannot believe the
traffic this is this should be more
disturbing to nd every I mean it's
glorious but it's the fact that you can
just try I just have my GPS popped up I
was deep and Lowe's felis and it said I
was gonna take me eight minutes to get
to the valley and I was like what's
happening this is this should be tariff
that be that was like of all the things
yeah and now now here we are door open
[ __ ] beautiful day to be alive Joel
McHale thank you very much you for
having me on a nicest man in comedy
you're a [ __ ] sweetheart and your
producer knows way too much about Carl's
juice oh yeah oh yeah please yes he
knows the stock options at McDonald's
right now he pulled this stock out I
love you brother fires I want to thank
Joel McHale again I want to thank all
you [ __ ] for checking in today
I love you [ __ ] you know I'm
saying Joel McHale is a savage you
[ __ ] the savage listen like I
told your Monday tough times don't last
tough people do I know you're being put
into weird positions right now you know
you gotta have a little faith and trust
what I'm telling you will pass through
this either together as a family we'll
make it work you know they're trying to
help people the most important thing is
to keep your [ __ ] sense of humor all
right laugh at [ __ ] you wouldn't laugh
at before laugh keep laughing exercise
you know throw punches up at the [ __ ]
wall anything to make this triangle
I'm a little less easier thank you for
letting us come into your [ __ ] living
room once a week I love you
[ __ ] you know what I got no
dates I want to thank you guys but most
importantly stand mind your business
avoid people listen man there's nothing
wrong with telling somebody to stay away
you're just protecting yourself and your
family you know you can only be so nice
in this life this thing [ __ ] kills
whether it's gonna kill you or me who
the [ __ ] knows what [ __ ] they can all
suck our dick with a church or what's
happening now [ __ ] I'm with you
you're with me and they want to be with
us have a great week
all right take care yourselves and I'll
see you Monday
tip-top Magoo ready to go to tackle
another week of this [ __ ] quarantine
all right kick this [ __ ] melee have a
great weekend
[Music]